environnement avec le sommet de nairobi
l'occasion de nous intéresser aux
énergies renouvables renouvelables et en
particulier celles dont on parle peu
mais qui sont une solution pour l'avenir
il s'agit de l'énergie hydraulique au
niveau des communes une alternative à
développer dans les régions de france
qui possède tant de cours d'eau florence
mavic sylvain gauthier depuis 400 ans la
roue du moulin de la forge brasse les
eaux de la tardoire petit affluent
nonchalant de l'achat route
ses propriétaires utilisent l'énergie
fournie par l'eau pour moudre du grain
ou casser des noix et bientôt chauffer
la maison
dans ce décor hors du temps une petite
révolution se prépare à travers ces
pièces métalliques il s'agit d'une
dynamo qui va permettre à partir de la
roue du moulin de produire de
l'électricité qui va faire tourner des
convecteurs voir aussi un chauffe-eau je
pense que ça va réduire de moitié la
note de la note d'électricité faire des
économies profiter de l'énergie propre
et gratuite de la charente qui coule à
ses pieds dominique lugol n'a pas hésité
lui à investir pour métamorphoser son
ancien moulin en mythe court central
les économies
de jeu je peux faire don avec
l'utilisation d'engrais turbines dont
quand les indépendants sont de l'orne
près de 3000 euros par an maintenant je
gagne
dominique lui gaulle rentabilise un
lourd investissement en vendant le
surplus de sa production d'électricité à
edf petite turbine domestiques ont
barrage pharaonique
l'énergie hydraulique tient son rang
dans la production électrique annuelle
sur un total d'environ 600 milliards de
kilowattheures celle que l'on appelait
autrefois la houille blanche en fournit
70 milliards une multitude de petites
centrales sont exploités par des
sociétés privées comme ici à saint
junien sur la vienne qui dit énergie
blanche dit absence de combustion et
donc de gaz à effet de serre il
centrales comme celle ci représente 800
tonnes de rejet de co2 dans l'atmosphère
en moins mais une législation
environnementale très contraignante sur
la gestion des rivières gêne le
développement de cette énergie
renouvelable
ce n'est pourtant pas l'offre qui
manquent si l'aventuré vous tente
cet ancien moulin vaut 1 million d'euros
chutes d'eau et klaus comprise